So Leute, jetzt gehen wir uns auf ein paar Runden Battlefield, ich habe vorhin schon
zwei Runden gespielt oder mehr, ich überlege gerade Bazaar, davor noch was habe ich schon
wieder verdrängt, ich kann mich echt in Battlefield nicht mehr zwei, äh Dings, Kark Island haben
wir davor gespielt und ich glaube das war es, ist auch vollkommen egal, ich zeige euch mal was Chat, ich
habe gerade eine Bazaar Runde erspielt, 91 Kills, 19 Deaths, 91, 19, null, also gebashed wurden sie,
Bäm, Bäm, Bäm, da muss Schläge geben hier, aufs Maul gab es, würde mir, ohne Mist Leute, würde mir
Warzone so viel Bock machen wie alt, wie alt ist Battlefield, dann könnte ich hier Huge Warzone
Content machen, aber die mir das Game nicht so richtig Bock macht, werde ich da auch nicht gut
drin, finde es anstrengend zu spielen und Battlefield flutscht, äh geht man auf Alley, warte mal, warte mal,
ok alles klar, ja flutscht sowas von, aber ihr müsst ihr schon zugeben, also ich meine das sind 10%
der Gegner Tickets, 10% der Gegner Tickets musste erstmal, erstmal weghauen,
doch, ich halte das auch immer nicht für möglich, aber es gibt tatsächlich ab und zu mal weibliche
Zuschauer auch auf YouTube, aber ich meine die Kombination aus Gaming plus noch Computer Informatik
Zeug, das glaube ich echt nicht der beste Content, wenn man viel weibliche Zuschauer haben will,
wenn der Chat dann solche Sachen postet, dann vertreiben wir die einigen, die wenigen die da sind
instant noch, so sieht es aus, so, ich würde sagen legen wir mal los, excellent, erstmal die Maul ein wenig
verkleinern, so machen wir mal an, so, heute spielen wir mal wieder ein bisschen ausgefallenerer Waffen,
ich mag das wie easy das ist, wenn das einfach rein zu joinen,
keck wait, auf welchem Sebar auf welchem Surfer waren wir denn eben,
dem oberen oder dem da, ja Rush machen wir nachher wieder voll, Mixed Maps waren wir eben,
spielen wir erst da noch mal eine Runde, 99er Ping stimmt nicht, das ist alles Debate,
2 Sekunden Leute, ich mach mal kurz die Musik aus, so nice die ist, aber, oh Karkhan, spielen die
bloß 2 Maps, ich hab Bazaar Karkhan und Kark Island gespielt bisher, oh Runde ist vorbei, nice,
oh nee Caspian Border, Leute ich glaube ich gehe direkt auf den anderen Server,
Caspian Border, da wird nicht gebashed, da wird die ganze Zeit mit irgendwelchen komischen Pants
man Sachen rumgestellt, und zumal ich, ich bin ja mehr oder weniger Infanterie only,
bisschen Panzerfahren krieg ich auch hin, aber das war's, ok komm wir spielen mal QBZ,
QBZ, QUPZ, realistische Beleuchtung, alles klar, QUPZ, Codra Visier, Laser, Heavy Barrel, jawoll,
exellent, so spielen wir jetzt QUPZ, wir können bei dem auch als Engie mal rein spawnen, mit MP5
ist natürlich doppelt dämlich, aber wir können ihn zumindest rappen, oder Kirby Musik machen,
oder Sebaru ist auch drin, oh nein nein nein, oh, Kegwaite, Kegwaite,
der Tank kann schon immer 3 Stück mitnehmen, wenn man den extra Slot hat, sag mal was ist jetzt
los, sind gerade beide Conquest Server abgekackt, alle beide sind die beim gleichen Hosting Anbieter
oder so, beide Server weg, Kegwaite, was ist da los, es ist ja nicht nur ein Server weg, es sind total
viele weg, ne das ist Hardcore, Hardcore spiele ich nicht, Kegwaite, wo sind die ganzen Conquest Server
hin, sind die alle beim gleichen Anbieter, wie hieß der Anbieter, wo man Venice Server mieten konnte,
die da, sind die down, oh was habe ich denn hier noch auf, ja da würde ich sagen müssen wir mal
kurz warten bis der Server wieder unten kommt, wird ja hoffentlich nicht so lange dauern,
wir können auch, ich glaube wir können auch Bazaar Night Spielen, war ne Runde, aber da sind keine
Leute drauf, Bazaar Pride Night, ok, schon wieder was neues, das mag ich an Venice,
da gibt es jeden Tag neuen Kram, Pog, aber da sind kaum Leute drauf, also wenn ihr wollt,
Joint rein, das wir spielten so was, wir spielen heute Leute, wir spielen, ach nee wir können jetzt, das ist der klassisches Server, ist der Ding, ah das ist ok, ich höre sie hier,
Alter ich kann mich nicht bewegen, ich konnte mich gerade nicht bewegen, habt ihr das gesehen,
es ging überhaupt nicht vorwärts, ja also wenn ihr mitmachen wollt, GG Eats,
ich hoffe man erkennt was, erkennt man gescheit was Leute, ok eigentlich will ich jetzt nicht
Bazaar Spawn Rapen, das ist ein bisschen Fail, aber Leute ich sag es euch gleich, ich switch
wahrscheinlich den Server wenn die anderen wieder on sind, also wir spielen jetzt ein paar Runden,
oder es geht voll krass ab, das kann ich auch sagen, so easy easy Rats, ich renne jetzt, oh da ist einer rübergelaufen,
wir müssen abfangen, ok Battlefield Logik, meine Meinung zu Warzone, ich hab ja gesagt, würde mir Warzone so viel Spaß machen wie Battlefield,
könnte ich die richtig krassen Warzone Content raushauen, kann ich aber leider nicht,
jetzt wollen sie es aber wissen hier, man merkt gleich, dass ihr wieder am Start seid,
guckt es euch an, Chat ist scharf hier, pass mal auf Chat, wir machen jetzt, ich mach hier den
Flank auf Doom und dann sind die alle tot, was soll das, Keg Triple Weight, also ja meine Meinung zu
mega, also mir macht Warzone nicht großartig Spaß, ich kann gar nicht unbedingt den Finger drauf
legen wo genau, aber weiß nicht, wahrscheinlich weil es Battle Royale ist, Battle Royale ist
halt so ein Ding, wo entweder du bist der krasseste Dude auf der Welt, du bist Huskers oder so was,
da kannst du permanent Aggressive spielen, aber der wird auch so oft sinnlos weggecampt,
dass es im Prinzip halt so Keg Weight Game ist, ich sehe den Typ nicht,
können die mal sterben please heute, der sitzt da in der Ecke, der sitzt da in der Ecke oder,
sitzt der da in der Ecke, muss mal, ich muss mal back, back fallen,
der sitzt da in der Ecke, ich glaube auch, dass der in der Ecke sitzt, okay hoffentlich ist bald
vorbei, Bazaar Spawn Rap ist eigentlich nicht so mein, mein Style, aber was willst du machen,
okay, okay Leute, wenn schon Bazaar Spawn Rap dann, dann richtig,
Keg Weight, wo braucht man für Venice DLCs, ne du brauchst nur DLCs wenn du sie spielen willst,
aber viele, aber viele Venice Server haben DLCs dementsprechend, es ist definitiv zu empfehlen,
die AIK macht zu viel, zu viel Muscle Flash, dass sie im dunklen das Ding, ah komm wir heben
einfach die andere Klasse auf, gleich viel besser, Keg Grip, immerhin selber voll, ja das ist nice,
nächste Runde ist dann ordentlich, oh Huge Rats, hallo ich kann hier aufstehen, oh Keg
Keg Weight meine Muni, das ist halt geil wenn man mit gescheiten Leuten spielt,
wenn man mit gescheiten Leuten spielt hast du auch instant Rats und Sachen am Start,
by the way wisst ihr, dass ich mit der Magnum einfach nix treffe,
ich kann mit dem Ding nichts machen, das ist unmöglich, guck mal ich bin ja noch drauf,
warum, naja, deswegen die werden umgerext die Gegner, oder schießt man das Ding aus der Hüfte,
das ist aus der Hüfte besser, lull ich hab den ernsthaft aus der Hüfte getroffen da hinten,
ok easy easy auf gehts, einfach Hüftenballer aufstellen,
nehm ich keiner trifft, was ist mit Inke los, oh Mist ich wollte das Equip von dem Typ Crammen,
warum hat Inke so viele Kills, ist Engie hier, oh der könnte ja eine Ammo Box droppen,
das wäre äußerst nice wenn der eine Ammo Box droppt, eigentlich wollte ich mein Equip wieder
haben, jetzt hat der mein Equip, oh was ist das, Alter was ist denn der hier am Start,
Monka was ist das, Inke was ist mit dir los, ist da irgendwas, ist da irgendwas, ok nice,
ich hab eine richtige Streamstreak, ja schon, du brauchst meine Hilfe bei Forever Sound,
der veraumt wird der Forever Sound leckt, was meinst du mit leckt, dass der verzögert ist
ne Sekunde, das ist normal, was du machen kannst ist ne USB Sound Karte dran, das war
richtig, ja stimmt, kannst ne USB Sound Karte dran machen, hier wechselt man das Team, du
gehst hier hin, klickst rechts auf, also nicht auf allen, sondern auf den meisten, du gehst
auf ein Scoreboard, klickst rechts auf deinen Namen und sagst Assist, in dem gleichen Menü
kannst du Vote Kicken, Surrender und Gegner Team Assisten, Assist ist ein bisschen bescheuer,
dass es anders gemacht ist mit Teamswitchen, aber ja, ist so, schon Battlefront 2 gespielt,
ehrlich gesagt ne und ich hab da auch nicht so das Bedürfnis zu Battlefront 3 zu spielen,
ok Kegwade, was spielen wir jetzt, ah ich will auf den Server wo ich Engi Waffen spielen
kann, das ist viel cooler, give Engi Waffen, ok wir machen jetzt erstmal Cover, ach komm
bleiben wir mal bei der AK, äh, warum hast du uns, warum hast du, Kollege warum hast
du genau da jetzt gesmoked, jetzt hätte ich jetzt nicht gedacht, dass die da zu zweit
um die Ecke stehen, freust du dich auf Battlefront 6, ne, ich glaube nicht die kriegen es auf
die Reihe, es ruckelt, dann kannst du in der Config Datei die Buffer Size größer machen,
wirst du mal, ich finde das, wie ich den Leuten sogar helfen kann, schreckt, oh jetzt kommen
sie von der anderen Seite, oh sind die da drin, oh Sandwich Mode, Sandwich Mode, Sandwich,
kein Subway, jetzt haben sie es aber weggesprayt, weggerext, beste Pistole, einfach zweimal
tappen Nahkampf, Gegner tot, wir müssen gleich mal, wir müssen gleich mal Weapon Stats gucken,
weil ich hab die überhaupt nicht mehr, what, what, was zum Teufel geht gerade mit den Gegnern
ab, das ist doch definitiv nicht normal, diese, was die für Damage machen gerade, was ist
denn hier los gerade, ist das, oh nee Leute, ist das der Server mit dem Spawn Bug, ist
das der Server mit dem Spawn Bug, es gibt einen Server mit einem Bug, da bekommt ein Team
keinen Respawn Timer, ein Team hat Respawn Timer und das andere Team hat keinen Respawn
Timer, was übelst räudig ist, easy Flank, jetzt wird Stream Sniped, ich sag's euch,
massive Streams, gleich kommt hier einer um die Eck, hier ist nie einer, aber hier kommt
gleich einer um die Eck, ich sag's euch, 1000 Pro, da war er schon, guck, ok die gehen
dahin, A ist safe, hoff ich, ich geh mal durch die Mitte, hä, ist der auf dem Dach, alter
ich komm hier die Treppe hoch, Monka, what, ah Mist, der ist auf dem Dach, Max der stellt
so, ey wenn ich eine Sache kann, dann ist es Rumstellen, Battlefield 3, nee aber ich glaub
der Server hat nicht den Bug, aber die Respawn, da stimmt doch irgendwas mit dem Respawn nicht,
guckt euch das mal an, wie die hier drücken, jetzt Nightwishen, ich schau mal sich ganz
sicher, ob ich den treff, ob ich den treff, nice, guck mal, habt ihr den Held gesehen,
oh fuck, habt ihr den Held gesehen, blind aus dem Treppenhaus rauf und aus dem anderen
Haus, wir switchen mal kurz, what, ich hab nix ausgerüstet, oh nee, das war halt eine
sehr dumme Idee, das war Pepega Idee, jetzt hab ich absolut räudige Kackwaffe am Start
vor mir sind 50 Trilliarden Gegner, Monka es, das war eine ganz doofe Idee, wo kann ich
das Buffering hochstellen, du musst in die Config Dateien da irgendwas eintragen, frag
mich nicht, ich musste googeln, warum ist die Waffe nicht equipt, die hab ich doch sonst
immer auch ausgerüstet, sind wir mal nett zu den Gegnern, nicht wegstellst, das ist nicht
mega man, das ist VVVVVV, was ist hier gerade los, wir laufen in die falsche Richtung, fuck,
ich seh die nicht, wenns dunkel ist, ich brauch eigentlich das Nightwish Ding, aber eigentlich
ist das noch hell genug, zack, what the, ich check grad nix, das ist Brain Overload, aber
da war noch wenig Tickets, what the fuck, was ist das, Kubis, Kubis, was ist das, der Damage
ist nicht, da stimmt irgendwas nicht, also 1.4.90 ist das eine, aber das ist schon echt komisch,
und jetzt gibt's, Alter, du bist legit, na dann, zumindest sieht der Damage sehr merkwürdig
aus, aber das könnte auch an den Server tix oder was auch immer liegen, sag mal, daher,
was ist hier los, ja 1.4.90 ist insofern, 1.4.90 ist schon ein Übel, aber das ist ja
alles one tap, zumindest siehts bei mir so aus, wahrscheinlich ist es bei dir gar nicht
one tap, sieht halt so aus, ok, jetzt bräuchte mir einen guten Panzerfahrer, Leute, und ich
bräuchte Nachtsichtvisier, weil so seh ich nix, seht ihr was, Achtung YOLO Modus, wie,
die haben mich nicht gekillt, Alter, was ist mit den Gegnern los, jawoll, Panzmann ist am
Start, auf, gibs uns, jetzt bräuchte ich Infra, Opensmann, nein, push, push, push, du musst
die Leute, ok, das war jetzt nix, wären da durchgekommen, scheiß drauf, dass der Panzer
verreckt, ich seh nix, ich seh nix Leute, legit, ich seh nix, nice, ich seh nix, ich
mach jetzt die Night Vision drauf, ich hab legit keinerlei Vision, ich hoffe es ist nicht
nur Bazaar Night, was haben wir denn hier schon zu bieten da, X, Captain Poggers oder
falls einer von euch da ist, sagt Bescheid, ne, da war mal Squad, ja, Battlefield 3 Nachtmaps
gibt es ja eigentlich gar nicht, das haben die ja custom gepatcht, normalerweise gibt
es nur, gab es das glaube ich nur in Battlefield 4, hä, wir haben das nicht gekriegt, ernsthaft,
seriously, ach das ist das hintere, fuck, ich guck mal was danach für ne Map kommt,
wir haben die Runde insofern gewonnen, wir waren schneller, äh was heißt schneller,
wir haben äh mehr, wir sind weitergekommen, fuck, jetzt müssen wir von da drüben reinballern,
Achtung Yolo, Yolo, fuck, hat es ja probieren können, mal gucken was jetzt kommt, wenn jetzt
wieder Nachtmap kommt, dann äh, hat sich genug Nachtmapped, denn mal Monster Hunter Relaxing,
du du du, ah, voten, voten, Tehran Highway, oh nee, dann, von Watt stehe wir Tehran Highway,
so, und wir sind beimельags in den
Gespräch oder so ein ganzes spiel was du willst
ja also
Kommt auf den server an unterscheiden sich immer ein bisschen in der regel das war deutlich höhere ticker 30 oder 60 14 10 im original
Du hast richtig coole custom sachen wie zum beispiel das
Bei einem server kannst du als medic auch engineer waffen spielen und sowas manche server mit blau filter weg
Du musst einfach mal ausprobieren ich finde es spielt sich viel angenehmer aber es spielt sich es spielt sich anders also ich habe das gefühl
Dadurch dass die hit rack mit 60 herz irgendwie teilweise
besser ist
verzeiht weniger wenn du vorbeischießt
Spielen wir immer ein bisschen mal ausgefallenes zeug spielen
Was im original halt noch registriert hat
So wo ist der sebaro
Ah ne hier
Ah das ist ja das ist kein server wo man wo man joinen kann mit mehr manche server haben nämlich auch
bis zu sechser oder siebener squads
Alter alter was ist hier los
Okay
Wollte das eigentlich aufmachen
Monka ist jetzt hat sie aber voll vergessen
Ich wollte eigentlich aufmachen dass ich neben durch kann aber noch keine chancen
Was warum ist das durch die wand explodiert
Sagt
Die sind alle da
Fuck ich wollte eigentlich ich habe eigentlich gehofft dass ich in der mitte meine sicht kriege auf diesen fünfer pack der darum krebst
Die man mag ich übrigens nicht
Kommst du her
Kommst du her ich kann jetzt hier nicht aufstehen wenn ich aufstehe krieg ich auf den zack
Der typ weiß dass ich da bin
Fuck
Konnte nicht schießen
und ich ähm besser gesagt ner Luv
Fuck, ich konnte nicht schießen, das sollte sich eben besser gesagt werden im Hübben.
Äh Moment, ich habe keine Orientierung auf der Map, wo sind wir hier überhaupt?
Und jetzt Rätts mich Kollege, Rätts mich doch einfach.
Aber der wird gerätzt, er wird gerätzt, alles klar.
Ist 10 Hertz überhaupt spielbar?
Ja.
Nee, es ist eher so, dass Battlefield 3 hat ziemlich Kleinzeit-Hit-Rack, so und dementsprechend
ist es so, du hast das verzeiht sogar bei 10 Hertz Tickrate mehr vorbeischießen als
umgedreht.
Ist eigentlich witzig, du hast total merkwürdige Hits bei Battlefield.
Oh die F2000 sackt mal auf Range, so krass.
Da war noch was.
Ich seh nix, wo ist denn hier was?
Ja klar, jetzt haben wir uns, das war nicht mal der Typ, der mich gebasht hat.
What the fuck, ist ja toll, so mal was anderes, bam, nee komm, post jam, post jam, was haben
wir da drauf?
Ihh, ey cock, wer will denn sowas?
Bingo Schuss.
Würdest du mit seinen Zuschauern im Squad spielen, ich spiel immer mit meinen Zuschauern
im Squad.
Okay.
Depends man, ich komm jetzt hier nicht raus, das ist mein Problem, ich will eigentlich
da wieder in die Mitte, weil die pushen da grad ganz gut drauf.
B3 im Single Fire, easy.
Das hab ich zu kurz gesehen, grad noch rechtzeitig.
Das Game verwirrt mich.
Alter, was ist hier los, Karrnt?
Okay, der sah sehr lebendig aus, muss ich euch mal ehrlich sagen, der sah sehr lebendig
aus.
Oh, mit der fucking Magnum aus der Hüfte, ey, wenn wir krasse G3 Action machen, oh,
der pusht, der pusht, der pusht, ich hab Schuss, der Pantsman schießt auf mich, der
Pantsman, der fucking, hohoho, Scheiße, wie heißt mein eigenes, ich hab noch kein eigenes,
aber G3 macht Bock, aber ich spiel hier am liebsten im Single Fire.
Wenn der Captain Poggers da ist, ist eh alles easy.
Nice, G3, G3, beste Alderlahn.
What, von wo, oder wie sagt man heutzutage, mach Auge, ich mach grad richtig Auge, weil
ich keine Ahnung hab, wo die sind.
Passive Auge, ja hallo, please, hit, ja klar, wir haben, wie wir uns gegenseitig gebasht
haben, fucking Healbox, okay, das war mir jetzt echt zu viel grad, ist ein eigener Server,
ja, ich würd echt gerne einen eigenen Server machen, ich hab keine Informatik, das ist
korrekt, ich muss mich mit der IHK rumschlagen, hat der Fallserver das Server, scheint, wo
sind die denn, oh der, ach der ist über uns, und die haben gesetzt, okay das ist schlecht,
die haben gesetzt, das sagt, da kommen wir hier nicht mehr raus jetzt, shit, wir müssen
irgendwie dahinter, ey, in the ass shooted und nicht registriert, okay, wir müssen, Leute,
habt ihrs gesehen, haben die das Mkomm gekriegt, ich hab's null, ich hab's null gecheckt,
haben die, haben die es oder nicht, wie er einfach vor mir aufploppt, ey, das ist das
gerade wieder, ah die haben das Mkomm gekriegt, fuck, das heißt wir sind zu weit, wir sind
zu weit vorne rumgehüpft, okay, ah Moment, das ist das Mkomm, verstehe, verstehe, verstehe,
das ist das Poggers Mkomm, oh nein, Alter, ich will nicht diese fucking Leiter hochlaufen,
Alter, okay, wir müssen in eine andere Richtung, der flankt, der flankt, der flankt, der flankt,
ey, der, der war doch gar nicht da, laut map, was ist hier, nice rescue Leiter, das war
echt so typisch Battlefield 3, wie so hoch auf einmal hängt er an der Leiter dran, ist
das, ist, ach, der Sebaro, du bist ja da mittlerweile, nice, man kann hier drauf, ist mir sogar neu,
ah, ist meiner, okay, der Pantsman, den ignorieren wir jetzt einfach mal, machen, stelzen uns
hier hinten lang, guck mal was gepascht, weggepascht, okay, ich geb zu, das war jetzt nicht, ah,
ich bin hängen geblieben, ich bin hängen geblieben, ah ja, ja, oh nee, ich dachte,
die Leute leben noch von mir, Sebaro, TG, Eats, boah, sag mal, haben die ersten Schüsse
wieder nicht registert, Server voll, ja, wird aber bestimmt gleich was frei, es ist
grad absolut chaotisch, äh, es ist grad total chaotisch, Cacquait, Cacquait, wie haben wir
das denn jetzt so schnell verloren, wie heißt der Server, das ist der einzige Server mit
Rush, wo die Leute draussen, guckt euch den Chat mal wieder an, wie der rumgeflammt wird,
Captain Poggers mal schreiben, Discord, Max Server, wir gehen auf jeden Fall von dem Rush
Server später noch runter und spielen noch ein bisschen Conquest, weil da, also vorher
übelst die Leute total zerrissen, okay, haben wir die G3 weg, okay, spielen wir den Klassiker,
Loadout, alles klar, passt, da, ich dachte, der Sebaro macht Heli, Stellz, wie ist eigentlich
mit einem, ich hab keinen eigenen Server grad, ja, ja, ja, ist gut Leute, äh, kann man den
nicht rauf, ich warte mal kurz, hübbe, hübbe, hübbe, okay, gehen wir mal hoch, okay,
gehen wir mal hoch aufs Dach und gucken da raus, ah, Captain Poggers ist am Start, jetzt
ist easy win, okay, wir müssen da mal ran, fuck, Monka ist, hier kann man übrigens durchschießen
und die Gegner bashen, kommt, kommt her, kommt her, kommt her, was, boah ey, vor lauter Explosion,
ich blick ja überhaupt nicht mehr durch, ist das mir zu viel Leute, das macht mein Boomer-Kopf
nicht mal mit, das, das schafft mein Boomer hier nicht mehr, nice, ich hab nur noch 11
Schuss, nice, okay, mehr hätte ich aus den 11 Schuss nicht machen können, aber wir packen
es glaube ich, Alter, wenn der jetzt eine Ammo-Kiste droppt, das wäre Massive Poggers,
na gut, was willst du machen, das snipen ist weird, ja, das stimmt, manchmal fliegen die
Sachen durch, ich hab auch noch nicht so genau gecheckt, warum, wenn ich ehrlich bin, so,
du könntest echt mal Ammo droppen, das wäre äußerst Poggers, ah, hat er es schön gemacht,
wow, wow, wow, okay, ich hol dich, ich seh sie, machen wir hier Stealth, jawoll, next,
Polo-Rats, ich check die Map nicht, ich hab die noch nicht aufgespielt, aber wir Stealth
mal von der Seite rein, das kann ja auf jeden Fall nicht schaden, kann man doch bestimmt
das, nice Stealth-Action machen, oder, oh, woher wusstet ihr das wieder, nein, Vollkorn
schietet definitiv nicht, den kenn ich, Vollkorn ist legit, über uns, oder, sind die über
uns, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, das war dumm, das war dumm, nice GG Eats, bist du
blind, Alter, okay, der, der Typ, der war echt blind, der mir da entgegen gelaufen ist
grad, oh, nice, noch ein Rats, oh, ich muss weg, ich muss weg, what the hell, die Hit-Rack,
die Hit-Rack ist wirklich sehr merkwürdig grad, habt ihr den, habt ihr den, ich bin
mir nicht genau sicher, von wo ich grad beschossen werde, irgendwo von rechts, okay, pusherino,
volle Pulle, er ist die Baro, Captain Poggers, ich mach nächste Runde, neue Squad auf, wenn
ihr wollt, oh nee, Leute, was ist hier grad los, wie gesagt, mein Boomer-Kopf explodiert
super, zu viel Action, da komm ich nicht mit, wo, wo sind die alle, lass mich hoch, game,
okay, da ist einer, der Rätts den, der Rätts den, ich weiß, dass der den, game, come on,
game, rauch, geh weg, okay, der Kubel ist wieder, oh, das sind Baro-Pence-Mans, jawoll,
da oben in die Ecke, bam, jawoll, okay, unsere Leute sind da grad raus, aus dem Loch rausgehüpft,
was im Endeffekt so viel heißt, wie, da können keine Gegner mehr sein, nice, okay, gehen
wir mal vor, ach, wir haben das M-Com grade erwischt, das, also die Map, die generell
muss ich sagen, die ganzen Epis-Dings, nee, wie, wie ist der DLC, Epi-Center ist ne Map,
wie ist das, After, Aftermath-DLC, kann das sein, die sind undurchsichtig für mich,
die sind echt undurchsichtig, kann man die eigentlich irgendwann mal hochlaufen?
Okay, hier kann man nicht hoch, nein, komm, reck dich, oh, oh, von hinten, oh, oh, oh,
von hinten, von hinten, von hinten, oh la, please, ich will einfach nur mal irgendwie
normal grad auslaufen können, ohne dass der Bildschirm wackelt, Leute, ich blick da mal
durch, zu viel, es ist legit zu viel, wo, was zum, alter, Boomer-Kopf explodiert, Boomer-Kopf
macht Boom, was, wo, wo schießt ihr noch?
Okay, Leute, ich, ich, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht kommentieren oder sagen gerade,
das ist mir einfach zu viel, dem auch, dem auch, der hat auch grad, wo zur Hölle kommt
jetzt der, der, der Typ daher, hat er sich zurecht gedacht, Achtung, der kommt gleich
hier raus oder irgendwo da, Brain-Damage durch zu viel Battlefield 3, weiß nicht, ob das,
ob das wissenschaftlich untersucht ist, ob das möglich ist, tu mal Jin-Pool, Boomer-Brain
kommt nicht mehr mit, aber 24-1, doch schon mal, okay, aber nice, nice für alle, die
mich gerätzt haben, äh, was, was stirbt hier, ich erkenne auch echt schlecht Gegner irgendwie
auf der Map, es ist alles so, so Schrott, so ein bisschen das Problem, was ich in Modern
Warfare permanent hab, dass ich nichts erkenne, wir gehen mal hier lang aufs Dach, gucken,
was hier abgeht, ach, hier ist kein Fenster, das ist natürlich doof, Hopp, Flank, Flank-Action,
Vmware oder Virtual Box, ähm, kommt drauf an, ob du Geld ausgeben willst oder nicht,
willst du Geld ausgeben oder kannst du Geld ausgeben, dann Vmware Workstation, willst
du's kostenlos, dann, äh, Virtual Box, schreck mich nicht so, Achtung, jetzt, die Legehenne
ist am Start, nix mal da, die sind aufm Dach, kann das sein, die sind aufm Dach, die sind
aufm Dach, der, der Typ ist dran, ha, Saved, Saved, Saved Leute, Saved, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, echt zu viel los hier, aber ich glaub, wir haben's, ich glaub, wir haben's, oh, ich
speicher das mal und nenn das Ding, Boomer-Hirn explodiert, das schreib ich mir jetzt auf,
Video-Ideen, Boomer-Hirn explodiert, BF3-Gameplay, äh, Mal-Kantz, irgendwas, wie auch immer
das Ding heißt, ähm, für die kostenlose Variante auch besser als Virtual Box, was
ist besser?
Ne, vor allem bei Workstation Player, mag ich nicht, kannste keine Snapshots machen
und sowas, dann, dann würd ich, dann würd ich Virtual Box nehmen, Snapshots ist so eins
der wichtigsten Sachen bei VMS, ja, Talamarket ist nice, oder, oder, Terran Highway, aber
Talamarket ist nice, Death Valley ist so, naja, nur weil's mir nicht gefällt, heißt
es ja nicht, dass euch nicht gefallen muss, so Leute, äh, Zebaro, Captain Pongos, ich
mach' neues Squad, könnt natürlich auch so alle rein joinen, sobald die Runde, Runde
gestartet ist, äh, Mal-Kantz Evening, what, warum heißt die Map jetzt auf einmal anders?
Muss man nicht verstehen, Battlefield Logik, übrigens die Lade-Animation finde ich auch
sehr schön gemacht, mit den Map-Screenshots, ne, ich spiel grad kein PoE, aber ich würd
gern, aber ich hab' keine Zeit alles zu machen, Post-Champ, Post-Champ, aha, ok, ähm, Foxtrot,
Zebaro, Instant-Click, ah, wir sind tief, Moment, ist, ist das ne andere Map?
Wait a minute, Cack-Wait, das ist ne andere Map, was ist das denn, ist das ne Custom-Map,
oder ne umgebaute, ne umgebaute Original-Map, Cack-Cack-Wait, what, das ist was neues, oder?
Ich glaub aber ich sollte hier nicht so weit vorlaufen, das ist ne umgebaute Map, ne, deswegen
heißt die auch anders, ouch, das, der Kubel ist wieder, deswegen find ichs auch nice, da
hast du immer mal was neues, ist der Pepega-Chat eigentlich da, oder der Five-Hat-Chat, ist
der Five-Hat-Chat da, Five-Hat-Chat, ja, das ist Death Valley nur am Abend, aber das ist
doch nicht die erste Base-Death-Valley, die erste Base-Death-Valley gehts, gehts, da ist
irgendwo das, ne, ne, ne, ne, das war was anderes, definitiv was anderes, die wurde
modifiziert, ja, ok, YOLO, YOLO-Rush, easy, easy, easy win, easy win, in the ass, I get
fucked in the ass over here, kaum was die Gegner gefunden, hab ich die Gegner auch erdeckt,
ja die ist eigentlich anders, Death Valley sieht, sieht wirklich am Anfang komplett
anders aus, also es ist, es ist Death Valley, aber es ist Death Valley, oh, Death Valley
modified, und ich bin komplett lost, was ich machen soll, wirklich komplett lost, Licht
ist anders, ja es ist aber auch, die Map ist halt auch komplett anders, ok, das, das erinnert
mich jetzt, Moment, das ist, das ist doch die normale Base, das ist doch die normale
Base, hä, what the fuck, oder doch nicht, lost, komplett lost, komplett lost, ah, aber
es gibt nen Rats, oder guck mal, schläg hinter euch, medics, please, das ist, das ist doch,
doch Sebaru du hast recht, die Map ist die gleiche, irgendwie ist es sehr, sehr merkwürdig,
normalerweise gibt es doch da auch einen AC130 und sowas, äußerst, äußerst verwirrend
gerade, haben die die M-Coms ein bisschen umplatten, nee, das ist jetzt normal, das
ist die ganz normale Base, AC ist auf dem Server deaktiviert, ok, was soll ich jetzt
machen, wegrennen, wegrennen, wow, ich hab null Plan, wo hier ab was abgeht, echt, null,
absolut null, ok, ich crawl mich jetzt zu den, die haben mich gesehen, von hinten, von
hinten, fuck, mann, warum piekt der, normalerweise pieken die nie, sondern werben sie erstmal
ab, meint es aus wie ein Gegner, von wo kommen die Gegner überhaupt, ich bin komplett lost,
ich bin komplett lost Leute, komplett, als hätt ich das Spiel noch nie gespielt, da drüben
fährt da so ein Panzer rum, die tropfen mir irgendwo Gegner rein, ok, Monkeys, ich check
nix, Leute, ehrlich, legit, kapiere absolut nichts gerade, aber man kann in Battlefield,
wo man nix checkt, was machen, der man einfach wiederbelebt, da auf dem Dach, ist der Typ
auf dem Dach, Achtung, die sprengen gleich ein Loch in die Wand, wie sie die Sprengstelle
hat, ich fass es nicht ey, wie die mich abfrühstücken, Bad Company, nee Bad Company spielt sich komplett
fast, Leute, das ist zu viel, ich bleib jetzt einfach hier drinnen sitzen in dem Haus und
mach nix, ja, Mauli, das stimmt schon, what the fuck, alle, hier ist, was ist das, was
ist das?
Zu viel, echt zu viel, aber ich bin ja froh, es sacken alle gerade, außer der Kubis, der
one tapped alles wieder, Battlefield 3 hat ein Rework bekommen, ja und nein, es ist Community
basiert, es ist kein offizielles Zeug, es ist kein offizielles Zeug, das hat auch ewig
gedauert zu entwickeln und es hat jetzt nicht die riesen Spielerbase, aber die dies hat,
hat es halt, weil es klingt jetzt wahnsinnig pfeifert, aber ich hab das Gefühl, es sind
die Leute, die jetzt damit anfangen, die sind eigentlich da, um auch hier zu bleiben.
Welche Map?
Das ist Death Valley, Death Valley mit anderer Beleuchtung und verwirrte Max, der absolut
keinen Plan hat, woher gerade irgendwo was herkommt, was sich abgeht, guck mal, die
sind, die sind einfach, wer ist mal mit sterben, Alter?
Ohne Mist durch mein Muscleflash, ich seh ja gar nix.
Ich seh durch den Muscleflash kaum was.
Ist der jetzt gepusht?
Ist der jetzt durchgepusht?
Ne oder?
Die Leute haben se.
Gut.
Und hier war irgendwo der Pantsman gerade da drüben.
What?
Ist doch durchgepusht.
Alter der Muscleflash ist ja brutal in der Nacht.
Oh da kommt n Panzer.
Hallo Panzer.
So.
Hab ich da grad was gesehen?
Und das ist straight, straight durchgeflogen.
Muss n bisschen aufpassen, weil ich nicht unendlich viel Money hab.
Achtung probier ma ma.
Oh von hinten, fuck.
Von wo?
Am Mitteln?
Normalerweise würd ich jetzt vorpuschen.
Auf jeder anderen Map würd ich jetzt vorpuschen und hier den Yolo Max machen.
Mach ich jetzt auch.
Die wissen's einfach, die wissen's, die wissen's, die wissen's.
Der wird extrem schnell, das sag ich doch.
Da guckt er einfach.
Spielt er an Mündungsbremse, ja so n Kack spielt man ja auch nicht.
Manchmal spielt eigentlich nur schwerer Lauf, okay oder manchmal Schalldämpfer.
Ich hab Commissar Rex dabei, ja.
Commissar Rex am Start.
Okay Achtung, Achtung, Achtung Leute.
Die holen wir jetzt.
Ich weiß, ich hoff nur ich bin zuerst da.
Okay, okay easy, easy, easy kill.
Was ein Timing, dass die jetzt gerade den Berg hoch pushen, während ich den Typ kill.
Aber zumindest ist es slow, der viel zu Batman ist am Start.
Schneibermann.
Wenn es jetzt Far Cry wäre, könnte ich das Öl entzünden, aber zum Glück ist es kein
Far Cry.
Ist das eigentlich mittlerweile bestätigt, dass der Junge aus Far Cry 6 war es ist als
er klein war?
Ich fänd's immer noch den Ultra Ubisoft Move, so nachher so was anzudichten dem Charakter.
Was, please Battlefield, wie kommt man hier rein?
Okay, ich defuse einfach, easy, nice, die kommen bestimmt von hier gleich wieder angestellt.
Sag mal kann das sein, dass die übelst, dass die übelst Gamma hochgepumpt haben, weil die
nicht das alles sehen, ich seh nix, wo man ihren überlastet wieder.
Fuck, Alter, die Narbe am Auge ist auf der falschen Seite, okay ist nicht was.
Okay, ich brauch ne Map, wo ich Ahnung hab, was ich mache, das ist mir zu verrückt.
Vorher noch 91 Kills Bazaar und jetzt 15-9, so geht's gehen.
Okay, jetzt rennen wir einfach mal YOLO auf die Gegner zu, easy.
Oh nein, nein, nein, Arle, shit, okay zum Glück ist die Map vorbei, vote, give next Map.
Ach nee, wir müssen ja noch Attack spielen, feelsbadman, no, no, Map is shit, ja es spielt
sich nicht schön, denn alle Taschenlampen, ich glaub Taschenlampe auf der Map ist nicht
gut, weil dann seh ich die Gegner ja schon, voll grad, ist klar.
Der scheiß Knopf, ja ich versteh auch nicht warum die Leute das voten, ich find die übelst
kacke.
Und jetzt spielen wir Death Bridge Knight, so, G3, easy, jetzt werden sie weggestellt,
ich überhol jetzt den Tank, aber links, wieso ist der Panzer schneller als unser Quad, Verkehrsregeln,
es gibt Pluspunkte, Achtung, Battlefield, ich seh nix.
Cap'n Porgas, ich hol dich, falls du noch lebst, nein.
Wo ist hier, wo hier geht hier was, Monka ist, vielleicht sollte man hier wirklich mal
ein bisschen auf Range visier oder so spielen, da kommt gleich was von hinten, wir sind null
Checks wo hier was ist, die sehen mich und sind krass, ja mit der Taschenlampe, das Problem
ist aber, dass die dich schon weiter sehen, also Taschenlampe ist glaub ich hier Selbstmord,
Kommando, sollen wir mal, Gunship Drop, ach deswegen haben die immer den unserer Base
direkt rumgestellst, jetzt hab ich's auch kapiert, das ist genau, das ist der Server,
wo das AC Disabled ist, aber du kannst dort Spawnen, ich verstehe, guck mal wie gut die
uns sehen, seht ihr das, wie die einfach hinten, jawoll YOLO, kann es mal weniger wackeln,
ich retz euch Leute, ich retz, hinter mir, was hast du für ne Grafika 1080 Ti, nice danke,
ok ich spiel jetzt holo, ich spiel holo visier danach, da seh ich ein bisschen mehr glaub
ich, wir haben jetzt Mcom schon, vielleicht haben wir die Map gleich vorbei, dann können
wir wieder was ordentliches spielen, irgendeine Map wo ich durchblicke und weiß was ich tue,
oh da kommt ein Panzer, der Panzmann, nein, lässt du mich in Ruhe, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
toll, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ok, ok, ok, ok.
Okay, nicht gehittert.
Es ist mir absolut unbegreiflich, was überhaupt um mich herum passiert auf der Map gerade.
Aber richtig krass wäre ich...
So, wir machen das mal mit Holo, dass ich vielleicht ein bisschen was hitte oder wir
spielen was anderes.
Das kann man dann...
Holo...
Kannst du das da führen?
Ja, nein.
Mit Silencer war die Kacke, ne?
Packweight.
Au, au!
Nee, X7 Scope ist doch der Sack.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es so eine gute Idee ist, wenn wir da reintrocknen direkt.
Ja, Holo ist ein bisschen größer wenigstens.
Dann kriegen wir damit vielleicht was auf die...
Wird die mich sehen?
Leute, wie sehen die mich... ich sehe auf zwei Meter keinen Gegner hier.
Beschweige, dass das was trifft.
Okay, easy.
Easy plant jetzt.
Oh man, da lebt noch der Tube, den die gerätzt haben.
Auch nicht.
Moment, Moment, wir gehen jetzt gar nicht, wir gehen außen rum.
Packweight, das glaube ich besser.
Irgendwo hier lang stellst du ihn.
Nee, der Tube gerätst nicht, das ist zu weit weg.
Braucht drei Stunden für.
Ich weiß auch nicht, wo ich hin...
Chat, wo laufe ich überhaupt hin?
Wo laufe ich denn überhaupt lang?
Süden, grobe Richtung, ja aber eher nur ganz grobe Richtung.
Okay, ich warte, was von der Map kommt und wenn die Map mir nicht zusagt, dann ist gleich
Conquest angesagt.
Ist das letzte Base?
Warte mal, letzte Base ist ein M-Com in so einem Bunker drin, ist das B in dem Bunker
drin?
Dann ist das vielleicht letzte Base, dann haben wir es gleich geschafft.
Wir haben es gleich überlebt.
Guck mal in den Battlefield-Chat, Complete Mayhem, ja hat er recht.
Ich hab keine Ammo-Knappheit, so meistens nicht.
Packweight, jetzt wird er noch abgeliegt.
Okay, ich komm echt null klar auf dem Ding hier.
Nice Rats, easy.
So, Moment, ich muss jetzt irgendwas anderes switchen.
Sebaru, easy, du bist erster, weil du mich so oft retzt, oder?
Komm, wenn gar nichts mehr geht, wenn gar nichts mehr geht, oh was ist denn das?
Ah, oh nice, ich hätt das die ganze Zeit spielen sollen, Leute, das hätt ich die ganze Zeit
spielen sollen.
What the fuck, jetzt hätt ich die ganze Zeit spielen sollen, jetzt weiß ich auch, wie
die mich alle sehen.
Komm mal hier, jetzt weiß ich auch, wie die mich alle immer 50 Trillionen Kilometer sehen.
Einfach, einfach M16 reinwischen.
Guckt's euch an, das ist doch noch nicht die letzte Base, oder?
Nee, das ist noch nicht die letzte Base, da kommt noch eine.
Okay, jetzt machen wir ein paar Kills, okay, zack, du weißt, kaum sieht man die Gegner,
man funzt das auch, oh, what the, komm mal, du siehst die gar durch Bäume durch, sehr
gut, excellent, würd ich sagen.
Ja, das ist die letzte Base, die letzte Base ist in so einem Bunker drin.
Blankerino, nein, nein, nein, lass mich, lass mich in Ruhe, lass mich, lass, ich bleib
einfach liegen, Leute, ich bleib einfach liegen und bewege mich nicht, dann sehen die mich
nicht, easy, nice, tactics, okay, das war nix, okay, jetzt haben wir wenigstens schon was
zu killen mit der Waffe und dem Aufsatz, ganz schön, das ist halt voll OP, dass du da reintropfen
kannst von oben, guckt euch das mal an, wie nice das ist, oh, äh, geht hier was?
Sehr fair, ja klar, nice, oh, oh, von hinten, breads, please, äh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
äh, jetzt hab ich doppelt enemy killed gerade bekommen, okay, verstehe, cack wait, was ist
mit den 1.4.90 Dudes eigentlich los, die, die, die killen einen so übel schnell, lebaro,
okay, ich glaub wir haben's gleich, Leute, ich glaub wir haben's gleich, ich glaub wir
haben's, ich glaub, Gott sei Dank ist das vorbei, oh, komm lass mal was gescheites
spielen jetzt, meine Güte, oh, das ist ja huge anstrengend, okay, wenn's demma ping,
äh, demma ping, ja, also wenn's demma ping wird, dann spielen wir das noch, danach wechseln
wir auf ne runde Conquest, Conquest, die Spielerzahlen sind okay, der Anfangshalb ist rum, ja, der
Anfangshalb war nach zwei Tagen schon rum, aber ich würde sagen, jetzt ist es ziemlich
stabil, es sind zwei, drei Server abends am Start, es sind auch immer die gleichen Server
am Start, es gibt meistens eins, zwei Conquest-Server und ein Rush-Server, oder eins, drei Conquest-Server,
ein Rush-Server, und ich hab das Gefühl, die, die jetzt halt anfangen, sind halt auch, spielen
jetzt halt auch, um, um zu spielen, um da zu bleiben, ja, irgendwann erstes Quartal kommt
auch der Reality-Mod raus, da bin ich ja mal gespannt, ist für die ganzen Squad-Spieler
bestimmt mal cool, ach nee, es ist, es ist demma, es ist, äh, Custom-Demma-Wend-Peak,
sonst wär das auch nicht genug gewesen, kann man gleich M16 mit Custom-Visi aufbehalten,
du, du, du, du, du, du, du, was haben die mit den ganzen Maps gemacht, nur auf dem Server,
es kommt, kommt ganz drauf an, die Nacht, die Nacht-Versionen sind eigentlich ganz cool,
aber, aber nicht, weil man sie zu oft spielt, okay, Post-Camp, Laden, Laden, ach nee, es
ist gar keine Nacht-Version, Customize, okay, haben wir hier auf jeden, haben wir hier auf
jeden Fall was Gescheites drauf, und wir spielen aber, ich würd sagen, wir spielen gar nix,
wir spielen, was spielen wir dann, ähm, und tatsächlich mal wieder AEK, und mal was ganz
anderes, was ganz anderes mal machen, Taktikaleit, lull, Standard-Map muss zu spielen, äh, wat,
keck, keck, wat, was mit der Map los, das sieht ja aus, als ist hier irgendwie ein Atombomber
explodiert vorher oder so, what the fuck, nee, ich schneide jetzt nicht, die Kammer in die
Modmark ist, wenn es an leash.com liegt, runter, und fertig, das wars, ernsthaft, wer
muss sich machen, du musst Orangeling, doch, du musst Orangeling gestartet haben, ich glaub,
die legen jetzt B, klar, ah, ah, Post-Camp, ich camp mal kurz hier ne Runde rum, wenn ich
nicht kann, der Typ ist oben im, oben im Haus, ne, sag mal, das ist, ist die Map lila oder
bin ich einfach nur, ist mein Kopf, mein, hab ich jetzt Hirnschaden von Battlefield
davongetragen, ist die Map irgendwie lila oder rosa, rosa, nicht lila, rosa, die Map
ist rosa oder, schon nicht total bescheuert, von wo, ja, alles klar Kubis, ist klar, ist
klar, die Map ist rosa, ja, sehr, sehr merkwürdig, äußerst merkwürdig, äußerst merkwürdig,
ja, sie haben in Battlefield 3 Blaufilter entfernt, aber den anderen eingebaut, ja, ja,
es ist echt komisch, sehr, sehr merkwürdig, komm, please, game, lass mich springen, Achtung,
wir machen jetzt Push, Push, Reno, ja, springt alle an mir vorbei, springt an mir vorbei und
ich bash euch dann, excellent, excellent, so machen wir das, hopp, springt an mir vorbei,
easy, okay oder auch nicht, fuck, die Map sieht aber noch nicht mal gut aus mit dem
rosa Stich, die Teams sind komplett unausgeglichen, kann ich jetzt noch nicht sagen, die Leute
waren dran, haben geplantet, kannst du doch jetzt, kann man sich noch nicht beschweren,
wobei es jetzt ein bisschen unfähig ist, ja, Tickets sind auch komisch, Achtung, Poggers,
der Server hat einen Hang da zu den Maps so zu machen, dass man nichts mehr erkennt, okay,
ich habe jetzt nichts gesehen, ich habe einfach nur auf den Muscle Flash geschossen, Top ist
alles weg, ja, okay, das war echt easy, du hast recht, die Teams waren recht unausgeglichen,
aber warum macht man den schönen Demavent Peak, warum gibt man den den rosa Stich, ist
das die Kappa Bride Variante, Demavent Peak Bride Week, oder was ist das hier, oh nee,
nein, die haben einfach mal geplantet, geilen Planter, nein, lass mich am leben, lass mich
am leben, ich bleibe jetzt hier liegen bis zum, ah fuck, was soll ich sagen, ich bleibe
hier liegen bis zum Ende der Runde, nein, jetzt verliert mich noch B, oh, Cack Wade,
die Farbpresets sind auch permanent der Admin hat es versammelt, ja, ich finde das sieht
nicht schön aus, die Sache ist aber die, das ist so alles neu, da kann man es mal verkacken,
ich bin bis zum Ende der Runde da liegen geblieben, jetzt wo du es sagst, ja, du hast recht, Spotting
ist nicht, ich glaube Spotting ist nicht aus, sondern nur, dass du Gegner siehst, die jemand
gespottet hast, hat die du nicht siehst, also wenn du ein Gegner, Cack Wade, ok, da kann
ich jetzt auf den, ich gucke mal, ob ich noch in das richtige Team komme, wenn nicht gehe
ich auf den Conquest Server, sind die Conquest Server eigentlich wieder da, ja, aber richtig
voll sind sie nicht, Maxi Map ist pink, steckt das Guardkabel richtig ein, nee, ich glaube,
das ist gewollt mit dem rosa, das ist Demavent Morning, der wollte, dass es nach Sonnenaufgang
aussieht, das ist Battlefield 3 Mod, Attacker, ist richtig, Attacker, wo ist mein Squad,
ich darf nicht rein, ich bin übrigens in Golf, by the way, jetzt habe ich die Kacke
ausgewählt, die wollte ich gar nicht, das wird ja voll, Moment, Squad, Foxtrot, Bäm,
ich bin wieder da, geil, jetzt habe ich Leute raus, Typ baited, by the way, ich will eigentlich,
aber laufe ich hier lang, normalerweise macht man das noch ganz, normalerweise geht man
von der anderen Seite hoch und dann hier lang, wow, what the, was mit meinem Nachtsichtvisier
los, der zeigt, er geht in rot an, okay, oh, oh, oh, okay, gut, sehr gut, sehr gut, sehr
gut, mega gut, hier ist der erste Spiel, da kommt noch mehr, gleich, ja, wer kann, der
der kann easy das war ein cooles play das gefällt mir das war ein nice to play
aber doch nicht nice so genug für für clips compilation einfach nur nice
oh sebaru absteuern das wird teuer
da könnt ihr mal aufhören um mir vorbei zu jumpen so dass ich euch treffen kann
ist happening
nice nice nice nice
jetzt, jetzt jawoll nein nein du schießt mich nicht ab easy,
wusste ich nice
wo ist der dude
lass euch wegsprayen please lass euch wegsprayen
lass euch wegsprayen jawoll ich muss halt Fenster
jawoll next jawoll lass euch wegsprayen perfekt
ja excellent excellent so muss das sein
mal kurz regnen ja spring
ok ich blicke nicht mehr durch zu viel wieder zu viel für den Boomer Kopf
zu viel für den Boomer Kopf wieder lebt noch
dankeschön
nein fuck dachte ich dachte ich kann mit dem Kit von dem Typ weitermachen
nein ihr könntet mich schätzen weil ich bin eigentlich gut da hat aber keiner bock
drauf
da hast du richtig hart gebashed ja muss muss auch mal sein
da oben geht was ab
da oben war was los
still base camping naja was heißt base camping die Typen sind halt verreckt und wir sind
gepusht und die waren halt noch da
oh nice nice cimbaro hat big brain plays am start
nein nein nein Kollege so nicht so nicht so nicht so nicht so nicht
keck wade keck wade keck wade keck keck wade wo sind wir wo sind wir wo geht was ab
ok ich bleib jetzt im Auto drin
ok kann man nicht wallbanging
kommt man hier raus
natürlich liegt da ne mine wer spielt auf der map mit minen hier gibt es nix
hier gibt es nix aber aber mit minen spielen
das ist mal das war echt richtiger keck wade moment was ist da warum mit minen ok ich ganz
ehrlich wenn ich support habe dann würde ich das auch machen weil dort fahren sie
immer mit dem auto rein
deswegen wahrscheinlich würde ich da auch minen hinlegen
haben die das weiter rüber gemacht auf der map nee oder das bisschen vielleicht so
zwei zentimeter das ist out von der map
ob das trifft keine pro gamer nade
keine pro gamer nade keck wade warum
ich will ich an die leiter na komm gehen wir hoch
das ist mir zu viel wie da grad boomer hier in explodes
ok das ist zu viel zu viel für mich am abend
ok durch hier raus hier aber wir müssen kirby musik machen jetzt weiß
ich auch woran es liegt dass ich so überfordert bin
kirby musik ist nicht an sekunde jawoll
jetzt ist wieder gut jetzt wieder gut
darf ich ruhig einer retten wir liegen direkt davor
der stells da unten irgendwo rum egal wie mich beschäftigt mich überhaupt nicht
mit denen in der base ich trappe jetzt einfach runter
einfach easy drop easy plant
die sind aber auch aggressive hier nein
der hat grad turbo krabbeler gemacht
hier wir kämpfen jetzt mal hier den ausgang ab
wir kämpfen den ausgang ab perfekt
perfekt ausgang ab camper so muss es sein
perfekt ausgang abgekämpft so muss es so und nicht anders
oh ich kann jetzt nicht runter
ihr könnt bei mir spawnen spawn bei mir leute spawn bei mir
ich versuche mir hier mal ein bisschen zu zu verstecken
und dann gehen wir dann gehen wir hier hier durch
die sind wieder ganz scharf auf mich ganz scharf auf mich sind die
was was der ist nicht gestorben
lull wollen wir schwäpeln
na klar
49 schneibermann 49
waldpariser waldpariser war auch massive poc wir haben übrigens die base schon
da vorne war noch einer ich sag's nur
hier das war doof wurde vfw hätte schon optimiert da ist
überhaupt kein unterschied zu sonst
gestorben wird aber definitiv kann ich
die ist ja schon immer am einschlägt
warum bettel viel auf der neuen xbox schlechter aussieht
das läuft doch gar nicht auf der neuen xbox nur als beckmords compatibility und
das sollte eigentlich mehr oder weniger identisch
zum original aussehen eventuell ein bisschen besser durch
irgendwelche post processing anti lasing geschichten oder so
ok normalerweise ist immer einer drinnen nein nein kein quake kein quake
die gegner sind nicht dumm die gegner sind nicht dumm das merkst du die sehen
ein skip geht man diesen zu komplett brain afka und checken gar nicht wenn man
da ist die die kapierens
was soll das leister sporn easy
ja und auf der konsole und auf der konsole 30 fps ja
beide wussten dass man hier hoch kann und da aufs auto hüpfen das ist in
konquest hier teilweise sehr praktisch
da war einer links ich hab's gesehen
ich hab da grad irgendwie was gehittet noch habt ihr das gesehen
über was ist der grad rüber gehüpft
da sieht mich das ist nicht dumm das ist nicht dumm da ist nicht dumm
bliebst du musst du einfach nur vor die retten alter
also jetzt wird es anstrengend jetzt wird es anstrengend die baro
bin ich bester bester sporn was aus meinem eigenen server geworden ist noch
nichts ich bin aktuell ziemlich zufrieden mit den
servan die da sind kann man top spielen 3 und 5 12 was geht mit dem
karab was spielte denn jetzt blies korn leute ihr müsst euch doch einfach nur umdrehen
hier
Wie genau trifft eine panzer hier legit legit frage
Teils drauf nein
Lost lost aber trotzdem coole runde
Ich gehe jetzt auf den
Conquest oder Conquest in eine runde ihr habt ihr verloren ich habe keine ahnung
Just do it
Wo sind die Conquest Server
Wo sind die Conquest Server? Darkness Unleashed? Ne ne ne ne ne
Ne ne ne ne ne okay wir bleiben bei Rush wir bleiben bei Rush was soll man machen
Ne? Captain Penguin welchen schlägst du vor? Server voll machen naja ok
Dann nehmen wir, lass mal kurz gucken
Wir nehmen
Ich bin gekickt worden alles klar nice
Also wir spielen definitiv nicht hardcore one shot headshot das halte ich heute nicht mehr aus
Das geht wir müssen den annehmen Stryker Karkans 7 von 74
Weil auf noch mehr nachtmaps habe ich heute kein bock
Das ist der Server wo man die Engi Waffen spielen kann
Man spielen wir mal ein bisschen
Ich spiele ein bisschen QBZ
Kupz
Kupz jawoll was war man da drauf
Ja das kann man tatsächlich so spielen
Kupz des Todes of Doom exquisite
Ich finde die maps sieht richtig gut aus ohne Plaufilter drüber
Ich finde das nice wie schnell wir den Server voll haben immer
Poggers freue mich dass du hier Witz machst ich habe schon auf dem Server jede Menge Videos
Aufgenommen
Kupz
Equate
Ist der beste障isure haben
Easy Schleim-Action, nice.
Toll, Leute, ich frag mich, wenn das bei mir schon immer noch so ist.
Was ist denn grad mit aktuell angesagten Content-Creatern?
Äh, eigentlich voll nicht aufs Dach.
Ich find's ja nice, freut mich ja.
Das den Leuten so gut gefällt.
Abonniert, Honey, Bachelor, Sloth.
Danke für den Sub.
Guck mal, Server voll, easy.
Nee, Server ist noch gar nicht voll, stimmt ja gar nicht.
Das ist ja ein 64-Mann-Server.
Äh, 74-Mann-Server.
Oh, Kupps, Leute. Die Kupps ist am Start.
Kupp, what?
Alter, ich wollt euch mit der Kupps ownen.
Wo sind wir denn hier am Start?
Ehh.
Kupps, Alter.
Bam.
Au.
Aber schläg im Waggon.
Das ist gut, im Waggon kann man ratzen.
Hier, X.
Spawn.
Spot, spot, spot. Ich seh nix.
Geht hier was?
Ah, da hinten.
Okay, das ist auf Range mit der SMG eher nicht so gut.
Ich wüsste ja eigentlich, dass ich das extrem nice finde, dass man hier Engi-Waffen spielen kann.
Auch wenn die Engi-Waffen eigentlich fast alle unterlegen sind gegenüber den Assault Rifles.
Oder eigentlich alle.
Was ist denn das hier?
Oh, oh, schlechte Idee, schlechte Idee, schlechte, schlechte, schlechte Idee.
Kupps.
Moment, was? Der hat das überlebt?
Seriously?
Flotsor.
Bester Name.
Oh, ist gut. Mr. Flotsor.
Oh.
Hab mich weggesprayt.
Ice Rats.
Gg Eats.
Oh nee, jetzt ist wieder der Spring verbackt.
Sag mal, was ist hier grad los?
War der Defi schon immer pink?
Nein, das ist der pinke Server.
Da ist alles pink.
Da ist der Defi pink.
Und ähm, was ist es noch?
Es sind noch ein paar Sachen.
Noch ein paar Sachen sind pink.
Okay, der hat keinen Bock zu sterben.
Auch gut.
Die Kupps, Alter.
Die Kupps euch.
Kupps. Oh nee.
Ausgekuppst.
Aber QBZ geht.
Ist vom Damage her übrigens genauso schlecht wie alle anderen SMGs.
Aber fühlt sich aus Gründen, die mir sich mir nicht erschließen, besser an.
Was?
Jetzt kommt der Grad von hinten, der man durch um die Ecke geht.
Das Iron Sight ist übrigens auch pink.
Das Iron Sight, also das Cobra Visier ist teilweise auch pink.
Alter, was? Unlucky hoch drei.
Also irgendwie ist der Damage teilweise echt unnormal, den manche Leute machen.
Das Spiel sieht anders aus ohne Plausch.
Aber richtig, also extrem viel anders.
Da können wir jetzt nicht hoch.
Die awnen uns.
Vielleicht können wir hier langstelzen und gucken.
Guck mal, ich hab dem Typ zweimal in den Kopf geschossen.
Deswegen sind SMGs auf Range kacke.
What?
Ach so, der war hinter mir.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, ich hab nen Sniper Schuss gehört und dann seh ich ACWR tot.
Keck wait.
Nehmen wir das gerade ein oder stehen wir hier rum?
Kurz campen.
Der Laser ist auch pink, ja.
Was?
Ernsthaft, der ist nicht gestorben?
What the hell?
Wo ist der eine Dude nicht gestorben?
Okay, nice hit detection, GG Battlefield.
Tim Server hatte ich vorhin, bevor ich Stream an gemacht hab, an der 1.19.19 Basarrunde.
Richtig nice.
Hups.
Das sind keine Ranges für SMGs in Battlefield hier.
Die schneibern uns, die schneibern uns weg hier, das kannst du vergessen.
Wie?
Ich fass es grad nicht.
Kann doch nicht sein.
Normalerweise sprayst du die easy weg.
Hier, da steht er.
Unter uns, unter uns.
Ja, da vorne stellst du was.
Easy.
Hups.
Ach hier.
In your face.
Die sind auf der anderen Seite.
An F stellsten die alle.
But why?
Mega bekannter Twitch hier, bekannter als immer, ja ist klar.
Nice, leaked Leute, jetzt ist es raus.
In Wahrheit sind es gerade keine 192 Zuschauer, sondern 19.200 Zuschauer.
Twitch, Twitch, Twitch Anzeige back.
Odullmet, weil Strongs Business Leute da rumsitzen, die solche Entscheidungen treffen.
Das war voll vergessen hier.
Ich mein allein mit Tickets sollten wir easy gewinnen.
Wir kommen hier nicht gescheit rüber, wenn die da campen.
Aber das gute ist, wenn die da campen, dann machen die sonst nichts.
Nur ist meine SMG auf die range wirklich nicht gut.
Auf, auf, auf, ich seh dich.
Du hast auf mich.
Ist er tot.
Wir sind hier auf der anderen Seite.
Jetzt müssen wir, jetzt müssen wir gecapturen.
Wir gehen durchs Haus.
Haben wir eine Chance, hier eigentlich hochzukommen von der Seite aus?
Easy.
Was ist da oben los?
Jetzt nehmen sie alle auf der anderen Seite.
Was ist das?
Warum ist der nicht tot?
Ich wollte gerade sagen, wer Kubits hättet.
Das hat nicht auf den letzten Typen.
Danke fürs Spiel auf unserem Server.
Was?
Ich spiel oft da.
Top Server.
Was ich richtig geil gemacht hab, ist, dass man die Waffen auswählen kann.
Vom Engineer.
Besser wäre es wahrscheinlich was anderes zu spielen.
Aber das ist einfach ein bisschen Abwechslung.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wo ich hinziehen soll.
Achtung, Yolo, Yolo, easy, easy win.
Jawoll.
Schwimme, schwimme, schwimme.
Schwimm, Schwimm, Schwimm, Schwimm, Schwimm.
Keck, wait, keck, wait, keck, wait.
In der S geschossen.
Mann, warum krieg ich von der Seite jetzt voll in der S?
Dabei hab ich mich gut umlaufen und hätte jetzt von der Seite alles killen können.
Aber die Kubits killt halt so langsam.
Das dauert ein bisschen.
Was ist mit dem Typ los?
Keck, wait, wo sind wir hier?
Ich hab heute schon einen geheimen Tag gespielt hier.
Also die Runden, die ich vor dem Stream gespielt hab.
Ich bin jetzt ein bisschen, schon ein bisschen erschöpft hier vor dem Battlefield.
Zumal jetzt die Rush-Runden auch echt anstrengend waren.
Von hinten kommt gleich was, Leute.
Den holen wir doch hier.
Oh Mann.
Battlefield, Keck, wait.
Sind die unten?
Die sind unten, oder?
Ah, die sind unten.
Nee, nee, sind sie nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, ich mach die Poggers Flanks und es zahlt sich überhaupt nicht aus.
Was?
Den Bogen?
Den Bogen, Alter.
Ich weiß, dass ich hier lang komm.
Alter, please, lass mir ein paar Kills da.
Keck, wait.
Please, lass was.
Da vorne.
Gibt da noch was?
Nein, fuck.
Jetzt, jetzt, nice.
Jetzt können wir Capture'n.
Easy Capture.
Achtung vor links.
Fuck.
Ihr könnt ungefähr die richtige Richtung hitten.
Was ist das?
Geht mir den Bogen, Mann.
Okay, Poggers.
Sind die down?
Ich hoffe mal.
Ich mein, wir gewinnen grad ziemlich gut.
Also, Kubis, ich hab keine Ahnung, was du machst, aber du One-Frames mich immer.
Was hat er für, was hat er für'n Ping?
20, überhaupt kein Problem.
Okay, ich wurde grad One-Frame von der P90.
Ich mein, what the fuck?
Was, was sind das für Kill-Times grad wieder?
Dabei sind's doch 60 Hertz, da sollte man zumindest die einzelnen Schüsse besser merken.
Oh, oh, oh, da geht's ab.
Pack Wade, pack Hyper-Wade.
Sag mal, das ist doch jetzt grad echt lächerlich, oder, was ist denn hier grad los?
Auf 60, die Kugel zählen doppelt, ja, so fühlt sich das auch grad an.
Pack, pack Wade, da isser, nice pink laser.
War das jetzt anders?
Lasst mir meine Kills.
Brauchen wir Damage mit der Waffe.
Kupz, alter Kupz sackt.
Mehr als den Kopf schießen geht doch nicht.
Was ist, ey, AS-Val über die Range?
Was sind das, was sind das für Hits?
Von da mit der AS-Val wanted?
Es fühlt sich besser an, aber das fühlt sich nicht gut an, diese One-Tap-Dinger.
Also das ist echt kacke.
AS-Val OP.
Oh fuck, da oben links einer noch, oben isser.
Richtig, richtig one-shotted alles hier.
Kaonoma, den haben wir öfter schon am Start gehabt, der hat immer so krasse Scores.
Okay, capturen wir mal schnell.
Moment, wo stellt der auf den Dach?
Macht der Dachstelz?
Ah, ja.
Wo ist das, der hat doch ein Beacon gehabt, der hatte doch ein Beacon hier.
Ist das?
Alter, da hinten, okay.
Hallo, nicht festhängen, please.
Fov, ich glaube 90, 90er Fov ist es, glaube ich.
Da oben 90er Fov.
Okay, auf die Range machst du mit der Kupps nichts.
Ausgekupst.
Aber Captain Poggers out hoffentlich.
Jetzt kommt der Mörser, Mann.
Okay, push.
Okay, jetzt müssen wir mal gucken.
Jetzt die Frage.
Also, irgendwas stimmt hier nicht.
Also, irgendwas ist hier auf jeden Fall nicht normal.
Das kann mir keiner erzählen, dass der ein Magnum One Shot macht über die Range.
Warum kein Overwatch mehr, weil Overwatch suckt.
By the way, wie geht es hier eigentlich hoch, außen, oder?
Okay, Leute, ist vorbei.
Ich bin am Ende für heute.
Ich kann nicht mehr spielen.
Zu viel.
Ich bin zu faul, in die einen Seite zu gehen, dann passiert sowas.
Aber nie, Overwatch suckt, da habe ich keinen Bock drauf.
Overwatch ist wirklich nicht mal das, was am Anfang gewesen ist.
Und ich frage mich, ob das mit Overwatch 2 besser wird, ich glaube nicht.
Ganz ehrlich, ich glaube nicht.
Ich glaube, mit Overwatch 2 wird es eigentlich nur noch schlimmer.
Weil Blizzard hat glaube ich bis heute nicht kapiert, warum ihr games suckt.
Wo soll das eigentlich rauskommen, Overwatch 2?
Das stimmt dem Leben nicht.
Okay, warum?
Das hat mich auch, mich hat es damals total gewundert.
Die haben das angekündigt, so komplett random, ohne dass du damit gerechnet hättest.
Und auf einmal war einfach nur Ruhe.
Und Overwatch 2 hat auf mich gewirkt, als ist es ein neuer Multiplayer-Modus und eine Singleplayer-Kampagne.
Was, was man eigentlich vor Overwatch 1 rausbringen wollte.
Papa Jeff regelt das schon, Papa Jeff regelt gar nichts.
Overwatch suckt einfach nur noch.
Ein kack Game-Modus und kack Map-Design seit Anfang an drin ist und noch gar noch mehr Maps.
Wer hat sich 2Cp ausgedacht, mal ganz ehrlich.
Vielleicht hier wieder.
Da steht überhaupt nichts drin in dieser News. Was ist denn das für eine News gewesen?
Ich bin raus, ja. Nee, ich konnte mich nur immer konzentrieren.
Wir haben ja davor schon gespielt und jetzt...
Ich war zu faul in die Ironsides zu gehen, weil ich gedacht habe, die Gegner kannst du so wegsprayen.
Das Problem ist einfach, wenn die Gegner halbwegs taugen, dann geht das nicht.
Ich hab gedacht, komm, bam, bam, bam, aus dem Hüft wegsprayen, aber keine gute Idee gewesen.
Das ist ja exakt die gleiche News mit keinem Inhalt.
Und dadurch, dass Overwatch 2 jetzt rumgewurstet wird, haben sie auch schon...
Der Content-Release und alle möglichen Sachen war ja auch in Overwatch 1 schon irgendwie total lahm.
Die Leute wollten mehr und haben aber nichts gekriegt.
Dass sie selbst nicht wussten, wie man ordentlichen Overwatch-E-Sport machen soll.
Sie haben ihre Overwatch League am Start und sie haben nichts. Sie haben kein Tier 3, kein Tier 2, kein Tier 1.
Sie haben nur quasi ST Overwatch League, was anderes gibt es nicht.
Okay, manche Leute würden sagen, ja, es gibt Contenders, aber Contenders ist einfach nur...
Das ist Contenders. Contenders ist so scheiße, dass sie selbst nicht mal in irgendeiner Art und Weise für Werbung machen.
An sich müsste Contenders nicht scheiße sein, aber was soll das? Was hat Splitser da wieder gedacht?
Und jetzt, wo die Overwatch League auf YouTube läuft, guckt es auch gar keiner mehr.
Der 0815 CS-Turnier hat mehr Zuschauer als Overwatch.
Das ist der Witz schlechthin.
Auch, dass sie bei einem E-Sport, was prädestiniert dafür ist, global zu sein.
So nach dem Motto Fans aus Europa, Fanboyen, koreanische Spieler und umgedreht.
Dass man sagt, wir machen das regional mit irgendwelchen Stadions und sowas.
Das ist so Last-Century irgendwie und Blizzard hat gedacht, das ist eine geile Idee, das machen wir.
Lustigerweise, in der Call of Duty-Liga haben sie die Fehler nicht ganz so extrem gemacht und die läuft sogar.
Wobei ich nicht sagen würde, dass ich Call of Duty-E-Sports eigentlich spannend finde.
Ja, dass sie die Teams unbenannt haben, fand ich auch fragwürdig.
Und das ist 2 Millionen gekostet, oder es hat 2 Millionen gekostet für... oder 20 Millionen? Warte mal.
2 Millionen, 20 Millionen Overwatch-Buy-In 2 Millionen, oder?
20 Millionen?
Ja, total, total rad. Mir ist es schleierhaft, was Blizzard da gemacht hat.
Aber Blizzard kann es halt einfach auch E-Sport-technisch nicht.
Muss man halt auch mal sagen.
Was hat Blizzard für einen guten E-Sport, den sie selber managen?
StarCraft 2 verschissen?
Heroes of the Storm abgesägt?
Hearthstone?
Naja, gut, es ist Hearthstone, das geht immer noch ein bisschen.
Overwatch verkackt?
Was haben die denn noch?
World of Warcraft PvP?
Vielleicht erinnert sich noch einer an diesen World of Warcraft PvP-Turnierskandal, den sie vor ein paar Jahren hatten?
Ich kriege das jetzt nicht mehr so ganz wiedergegeben.
Aber es war so der Spur nach, Blizzard sagt, ihr könnt...
Ihr könnt Skins und...
Mounds kaufen und...
Das kommt dem...
Das kommt dem Preisgeld des Turniers zugute.
Normalerweise hat Blizzard die letzten Jahre immer Geld locker gemacht.
Und dann haben sie gesagt irgendwann, wir machen kein Geld mehr locker.
Es geht nur noch über Skinverkäufe und davon dann auch nur die Hälfte.
Total random. Das war vor ein paar Jahren.
Und die Leute haben sich mega jebaited gefühlt.
Blizzard verscheißt es einfach total.
StarCraft 2 verschissen?
Ja, StarCraft haben sie auch verkackt.
Die sollen E-Sport Sachen machen, dass die Leute die Ahnung haben.
Und du brauchst... Das ist ohne Mist.
Du brauchst dafür, dass ein Spiel eine Hell-Szene, eine gesunde E-Sport-Szene hat.
Du kannst nicht sagen, ey, wir machen...
Wir sind Blizzard, wir machen Overwatch League und sonst nichts.
Wo sollen denn die Spieler herkommen?
Wenn es kein Tier 3, 2, 1 gibt.
Sondern nur S-Tier, was noch nicht mal einer guckt und eigentlich gar kein S-Tier ist.
Wenn die eigenen Pros das Spiel hassen, das hast du in keinem anderen Spiel.
Weil du hast sicherlich den einen oder anderen CS-Spieler, der sagt,
ja, ich spiele nicht gerne wirklich jeden Tag CS, aber ich verdiene damit Geld.
Aber du hast Overwatch-Pros, die hassen das Game.
Die sagen das öffentlich, die sagen, wenn ich nicht den Vertrag unterschrieben würde,
ich würde es nicht mehr anfassen.
Der MVP der vorletzten Overwatch-League ist zu Valorant gewechselt.
Der beste Spieler in dem Spiel wechselt einfach mittendrin zu Valorant.
Das ist so, wie wenn damals, keine Ahnung, Forrest Gatwright oder was weiß ich,
wen hast du denn da noch?
Keine Ahnung, sucht euch irgendwie so einen ultrakrassen CS-Typ raus,
der hätte quasi Spieler des Jahres gewonnen.
Und hätte dann gesagt, ach nee, ich gehe jetzt zu Valorant.
Oder, ja genau, Tiger Woods sagt, nee, ihr Leute, ich gehe jetzt Tennis spielen.
Das gibt es nur in Overwatch.
Und was dafür spricht, dass das Blizzard halt einfach verkackt hat.
Gatwright ist jetzt auch Valorant. Ich habe gesehen, Gatwright hat Valorant gestreamt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob der jetzt Valorant spielt, profimäßig.
Aber es gibt ja ein paar.
Scream macht ja auch CS und Valorant irgendwie.
Die CS-Spiele haben einen riesen Vorteil.
Gerade die bisschen älteren, die haben halt übelst, übelst Erfahrung.
Und ich glaube, du kannst als CS-Pro auch relativ schnell Valorant abpicken als Game.
Echt, Gatwright hat Pro CS gequittet, wirklich?
Habe ich gar nicht mitgekriegt, ich verfolge das nicht so.
Ist ja nicht mal, na gut, Indignitas muss man auch ehrlich sagen.
Die haben auch, die haben, ich will nicht sagen gesackt, aber die waren jetzt nicht mal wirklich gut.
Echt? Wo steht denn das? Warte mal.
Gatwright, Liquid, Pedia.
Hier war ich offline.
Ich glaube, bei dem, bei dem war ich offline.
Nee, da war ich, nee, nee, da wo ich offline war, sind sie zweiter geworden.
Wo ist der Nip zweiter geworden?
Das war Köln auf jeden Fall.
2000.
2016?
Ach, keine Ahnung, da war ich live, das war mir echt mal cool, so ein größeres CS-Event live zu sehen.
Klar kannst du den HLTV-Dings Link posten.
Interessiert mich.
Das hier Baro hat den Server zusammengebaut, na dann zeig mal her.
Ich stelle mal kurz auf Just Chatting um.
Alter, was ist das für ein Gehäuse?
Fantech, sind das die nicht mit dem Headshot, äh mit dem, mit dem Fantech Headshot Controller?
Moment, kennt ihr den?
Da sind die doch.
Passt mal auf.
Beste.
Die Maus, die Maus, Alter.
Wie das Ding aussieht, wie scheiße, guckt euch das Kabel an.
Alter, wie hält der denn die Maus, der hält die falsch rum, guck mal, der hat die Maus einfach falsch rum.
Das leichte Kabel kommt Ihnen dabei garantiert nicht in die Quere.
Integriertes Billig-Maus-Bungie.
Fetzige Leuchteffekte mit unterschiedlichen Farben, Helligkeit und Pulsfrequenz machen das Spiel noch rasanter.
Profi-Gamers sind begeistert von den Programmiermöglichkeiten für Maus und Tastatur, selbst während des Spiels. Auch Makros lassen sich Probleme einsetzen. Damit sind sie bei Flugsimulationen, Rennspielen und anderen Games der King.
Der King sind wir damit.
Der Name schon.
Das ist dann, das ist sowas, was die Oma dem Enkel geschenkt hat und gedacht hat, sie hat was richtig Geiles gekauft und der Enkel guckt sich das an und pfeffert in die Ecke.
Also, Sebaro, was hast du da für ein Gehäuse rausgesucht? Zeit mal.
Ja, ein Gehäuse mit viel Deutsch. Sebaro, was hast du eigentlich vor? Was, was, was willst du da einspauen mit so einem Ding?
Alles. Ja, man kann ja nie genug haben. Get Right Steps Down, ach, das war gestern ja erst. Get Right Steps Down from Professional CS. Ja.
Spielt Forrest noch?
Der ist ja auch mittlerweile Boomer, Alter. Forrest ist glaube ich 32 oder 33 oder so. Der Kerl ist einfach, der ist ungefähr genau vier Jahre, ziemlich genau, nicht ganz, Monatunterschied oder so. Der ist ziemlich genau vier Jahre nach mir geboren.
Ja.
Also, ich habe gesehen, dass er Valorant gestreamt hat. Ja, hier.
Interessant. Ich glaube, ganz ehrlich, ich glaube Get Right macht jetzt Easy Money, Easy Life. Der also, der hat es ja auch schon lange nicht mehr nötig zu spielen. Also, Profimäßig auf der Bühne zu spielen. Der hat erstens genug Möglichkeiten, Money zu machen und zweitens hat er sicherlich genug Money.
Ja.
Hast du Valorant mal ausprobiert? Nein.
Guck mal, ich kriege mein eigenes Video empfohlen. Auch gut.
Ja.
Und wer aber ein nach und sonst was, das ist dem System doch wurscht.
Ich habe sogar ein Nip-T-Shirt noch von, frag mich nicht, 2015 oder so.
Hier ist der Rest der Config. Okay, Sebaro, zeig mal her.
Im Monat, ja, das kommt gut hin. Aber klar, ich meine, hey, mal ganz im Ernst. Er ist einer der größten Streamer weltweit. Wenn der damit nicht Geld macht, dann macht damit keiner Geld. Also, es ist sogar wichtig, dass der damit viel Geld macht, weil ansonsten könnt ihr Leute, die kleiner sind, gar nicht überleben.
So.
Okay, Sebaro, warum dann 3900? Weil er verfügbar ist wahrscheinlich.
Ja. Sebaro, du wirst schon wissen, was du machst. Der Hardware kann man nie genug haben. Ja, das haben wir noch von morgen auf. Die letzten Videos gehen alle echt gut. So Leute, ich gehe ins Bett. Ist der Friseur noch am Start?
Nope.
Leute, wir sehen uns vielleicht morgen. Macht's gut. Morgen komme ich da ein bisschen fitter online, nachdem es nicht schon Nachmittag ist und ich schon ein paar Runden Battlefield gespielt habe, weil ich mich nicht mal konzentrieren kann. Dann spielen wir vielleicht noch ein paar Runden. Also, bis dann. Dass wir mal eine 91 Kills Runde on Stream erspielen. Das wäre schon nice. Gestern hatten wir ein paar coole, aber heute war nicht so. Wir sehen uns. Macht's gut. Bis dann. See you.